عليه بين اسرائيل ولبنان بتسهيل
من الجيش الاسرائيلي. اسرائيل
تتحدى بذلك حزب الله وشرارة حرب
قادمة. رئيس ايران ابراهيم رئيسي
الماضية موسكو تعود وبقوة فهل هي
ردة فعل لعملية جسر القرم ام
للسكك الحديدية مستمرة
والتحقيقات متواصلة هناك الالمان
يصف المتظاهرين بالذباب واعداء
ايران. تراجع روسي في الايام
الاسرائيلية بدء تجارب التنقيب
عن الغاز في حقل كريشة المتنازع
بالرد على الحوثيين والاشتباكات
تتجدد بعد فشل تمديد الهدنة فيما
دولية في مصر حسب بيان رسمي. في
اليمن المجلس الرئاسي يوجه جيشه
وزير الدفاع السعودي يبحث مع
رئيس القيادة الرئاسي الجهود
الاممية لتمديد الهدنة. اعلنت
شركة تنقيب الغاز انرجينال
رئيسة الوزراء البريطانية تعطي
وعدا قاطعا لاسرائيل بنقل
استفتاء روسيا لضم مناطق محتلة
كييف تعلن مقاطعتها بطولة رياضية
زيارات رئيس جهاز المخابرات
التركي الى العراق تعكس تنامي
النفوذ السياسي لانقرة في
المنطقة. بعد مشاركة القاهرة في
الديموقراطية المفتاح لحماية
الجزيرة. فهل تكفي هذه المرونة
حالة التأهب لحماية البنية
التحتية في البلاد. صحيفة العرب.
تغاضوا عن وعد بلفور في ولاية
شمال الراين عمليات التخريب
السفارة البريطانية من الى القدس
فهل سيتغاضى العرب عنها كما
يشتبهون بالتورط الروسي ليؤكد
قائد في الجيش الالماني رفعن
محاولة منهم للطلب من بايدن طرح
ملفهم. فهل يضغط بايدن بقضية
برنامج التحديث العسكري. وسنعزز
الانفاق الدفاعي وستكون المرونة
الجنود متأكدون انها للقتال
وليست للاكل فانتم تأكلون كل شيء
بينما على الطرف الاخر هناك في
الجزيرة التايوانية ووسط تصاعد
الذي يسعى اليه ابناء زايد? جيش
بكين الالي. الصينيون لا يتركون
وبعد قرار ذكرت وكالة الانباء
الاماراتية ويم ان رئيس البلاد
مفاجئ على العدو وسيتم نشرها في
المناطق المحظورة والخطرة على
العيون الضيقة عقولهم كبيرة
وواسعة. هنا شركة صينية تدعى
التوتر مع الصين. اعلنت رئيسة
تايوان القدرات الدفاعية لنا عبر
بوتين هو الذي بدأ الحرب في
اوكرانيا وبامكانه ان ينهيها.
تعلن عن اطلاق كلاب الية تنزل
بمسيرات من السماء لشن هجوم
متاحة لدعم تطلعات الايرانيين.
فهل تكون السعودية سببا في تحسين
يتوقف هناك وسيتحرك الى مناطق
اخرى. ويحمل بايدن ايضا كارتا
ستخفض انتاج النفط دعا السيناتور
الامريكي بوب مينينديز الى تجميد
لم يكتف بذلك بل اردف قائلا
علينا ان نستخدم كل اداة سلمية
محمد بن زايد يزور روسيا ويلتقي
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين فما
ستنتصر في النهاية رغم حذرها في
الحرب. يا رجل ستحارب حتى اخر
الساحة للامريكان ليصولوا
ويجولوا في العالم. نعم. فاصحاب
جندي اوكراني فلماذا لم يكن
امريكي؟ ومن قلق الاوكران الى
تشكل غصة في الحلق الامريكي. هنا
الامارات تدخل خط القلق الامريكي
العلاقات الامريكية الايرانية?
السعودية لم تعد الوحيدة التي
ملف للضغط واخر للتفاوض. جولة
بايدن سيبدأها من مصر لكنه لن
لمواجهة كلاب الصين الالية?
الاحداث والتطورات. ليزي تشريس
خاشقجي على السعودية؟ وبعد ان
اعلنت مجموعة اوبك بلس انها
المتحدة ستحارب في اوكرانيا حتى
اخر جندي اوكراني ويؤكد ان موسكو
القلق الغربي يزداد اكثر. وهنا
سيناتور امريكي يقول الولايات
خيبة امل وبعد ضربة اوبك بلس
بايدن يزور الشرق الاوسط وبجعبته
الامريكية. حيث نقلت وسائل اعلام
غربية ان اهالي وعائلات ناشطين
هجوم جسر القرم. تهمة لربما
تؤكدها شماتة الزينسكي ببوتين
المملكة بالمساعدة في تمويل
الحرب الروسية على اوكرانيا. بوب
التعاون مع السعودية وايقاف
مبيعات الاسلحة لها. واتهم
المتحدث باسم الامن القومي
الامريكي. من الضروري ان يتمكن
للضغط على دول المنطقة لطالما
استخدمته الولايات المتحدة
في مصر والسعودية قابلوا مسؤولين
في وزارة الخارجية الامريكية في
النوع دون رد او عقاب. بايدن
وسازيلينسكي ووعده بان تزود
بقوله اليوم جيدا ومشمسا في
الغالب في اوكرانيا. لكن لسوء
بالحمقاء. غضب بوتين يجعل الغرب
يراجعون حساباتهم ليظهر هنا
الجانبان الروسي والاوكراني من
ايجاد مخرج سلمي. كيرفي يستدرك
الامريكي. الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب يحمل
الاوكراني زيلانسكي لم يعترف
رسميا بتفجير جسر القرن يخرج
الحظ كان الجو غائما في شبه
جزيرة القرم رغم انه كان لا يزال
لتحديد هوية الفاعل بوتين يتهم
الاستخبارات الاوكرانية بتنفيذ
بوتين ويتحدث وشرر الانتقام
يتطاير من عينيه. نعم خرج بنفسه
من الهجمات الصاروخية المدمرة من
روسيا والتي وصفها بايدن
الرئيس لما حدث الغزو اطلاقا. اي
ثقة هذه ترامب ودعا ترامب لاطلاق
المستفزة لبوتين واضاف لقد
اجبروه على الغزو. لو كنت انا
الولايات المتحدة اوكرانيا
بانظمة جوية متقدمة تعرضها لوابل
دافئا. ليرد الرئيس الروسي ويقول
من المستحيل ترك جرائم من هذا
مفاوضات على الفور الصراع في
اوكرانيا. لكن مهلا الرئيس
البايدن مسؤولية حرب اوكرانيا
بسبب ما وصفها بخطابات بايدن
ليخفف قليلا من قلق كان يؤرق ومن
حبة موسكو المسكنة الى العتاب
القرنة لا يندرج ضمن مبررات
تفعيل العقيدة النووية الروسية
العسكرية. وسنشكل قوات اقليمية
مشتركة مع روسيا. فهل يعلنون
بيسكوف يطمئن العالم قليلا ويقول
ان الهجوم الارهابي على جسر
النهاية قريبا? لكن السكرتير
الصحفي للرئيس الروسي ديمتري
قديروف ليس وحده من يحارب مع
روسيا. فرئيس بلاروسيا لوكاشينكو
القوات الروسية اصبحت الان في
ايد امينة بعد ان تم تعيين
يقول فتح اوكرانيا جبهة ضد
بلادنا جنوني من الناحية
سروفيكن سيغير مجريات الحرب
فلماذا يثق به الى هذه الدرجة
دون النظر الى الخلف. وذلك حسب
تصريح واضاف الرئيس الشيشاني
الجنرال سيرجي سيروفيكين قائدا
للقوات في اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان
تسبب فيه بارضنا سنأخذ بثأرنا.
وهنا مستشار وزارة الدفاع
الصاروخية الروسية التي استهدفت
مدنا في انحاء اوكرانيا اسقط
والاشتكاء كشخص مغفل بل من
الافضل لك الفرار باتجاه الغرب
سمعه قديروف ورد قائلا. لقد
حذرناك يا زلنسكي من ان روسيا لم
ستكون هناك حلقات اخرى. ليخرج
زيلينسكي صارخا الضربات
اوكرانية جعلت زيلنسكي يدعو
الناس للتوجه للملاجئ قبل ذلك
كان نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
قد اكد ايضا ان المزيد ات قائلا
الاوكراني يضيفه ليس لنا اي صلة
بتفجير جسر القرم. هذا الصراخ
الضحايا واوقعت دمارا. سيعاقب
العدو على الالم والموت الذي
تبدأ بعد بشكل جدي وحقيقي
بالعمل. لذا توقف عن العويل
الدب الروسي. الحرب كر وفر.
صولات وجولات. ومن يكسب جولة لا
يعني بالضرورة انه سيكسب الحرب
وهكذا هي الحروب يا اصدقائي.
الدفاع والامن الروسي بوندريف
يقول موسكو بدأت اعتبارا من
والفائز من يضحك اخيرا لا من
يضحك كثيرا. هنا رئيس لجنة
اليوم مرحلة جديدة من العملية
العسكرية الخاصة في اوكرانيا.
سنكون اكثر حسما في عملياتنا
باوكرانيا. وذلك وفق وكالة تاس
الروسية. تصريحات تاتي عقب القصف
الروسي العنيف الذي شهدته مدن
اليمن تصعيد غير مسبوق. والحرب
تندلع مرة اخرى بينما اسرائيل
تعلن لحزب الله اللبناني وتركيا
تعبث في الاراضي العراقية. عودة
يجهزون جيشا من الكلاب فمن
يستطيع الوقوف امام هذا الجيش في
والامارات توجه ضربة للبيت
الابيض. واصحاب العيون الضيقة
ببوتين وبوتين يرد بقرار فوري.
ضربة بايدن يخرج من جعبته ملف
ضغط اخر على الشرق الاوسط
وواشنطن تدعو لمقاطعة الرياض
وقديروف يقول لقد حذرناك
واوكرانيا خائفة من قرار امريكا
وموسكو تقول لا تخافوا بايدن
يواسي زينسكي وزينيسكي يستهزئ
تتردد وقديروف يرد هكذا سيأتي
الانتصار. زلينسكي يندب حظه
هذه الا البداية ولتنتظرون في
الحلقات القادمة. عبارات روسية
انها الصحوة الروسية?